el cambio a mejor en las relaciones
entre ecuador e israel- fue el aspecto
más destacado por los presidentes de
guillermo lasso exagerar shock en su
encuentro en jerusalén en concreto lazo
afirmó que quiere que haya más ecuador
en el mundo y más mundo en el ecuador
gracias a sus socios estratégicos sobre
israel el mandatario ecuatoriano destacó
los logros económicos y de desarrollo
del estado de hebreo que en 74 años y
con la mitad de la población que ecuador
tiene una economía cuatro veces mayor
así lo ejemplificó lazo quien remarcó la
intención de negociar un tratado de
libre comercio éste junto a la
innovación y la seguridad son pilares en
la visita del jefe de estado ecuatoriano
algo que adelantó a la audiencia pública
y pareció salirse de guión es un pedido
de apoyo de israel a ecuador para que el
país andino sea miembro no permanente
del consejo de seguridad de la onu por
su parte ejerció que le indicó a
guillermo lasso que espera cooperar en
ciencia agricultura tecnología y
desarrollo en este último aspecto
resaltó la apertura de la oficina de
ecuador en la universidad hebrea que se
sellará este jueves cuando concluyó en
la primera gira de un presidente
ecuatoriano en israel